the joggin experience I wonder how long
it's going to take before the human race
eradicate that because I think if you
look at like Pinker's work and some
other people just studied violence and
abuse and all the various things that we
love least about civilization those
markers are going down sort of across
the board whether it's violent crime or
rape those markers are slowly going down
like how long does it take for there's
none of that part of it's part of it so
they say what crippled the Mafia was
just the fact there are cameras
everywhere you can't just drop bodies
all the time because it's you don't know
everybody's got a [ __ ] ring the cops
just go can we take a look at your ring
footage right and and you know you got
to make a getaway somewhere you're
always on camera you're always on camera
and they can do this they can just
follow the dots
well Snowden just posted something that
I retweeted it see we can find that
Jamie about China and the citizens are
sort of revolting against this constant
surveillance state that's overtaking
China I'm saying over the next ten years
is what's going to be America absent
sweeping reform this is the whole world
in ten years remember both parties in
the u.s. defend mass surveillance
programs
China's advantage here is not
technological but that there's no strong
civil opposition to slow the descent
into nightmare so China is not I'm sorry
I read it wrong China is not able to
slow it they're just slowly descending
into the surveillance date this is the
biggest one that's why that's why not
trusting your [ __ ] leaders is very
important we were lied to and
Afghanistan for 18 years by senior US
officials the authorities can scan your
phone track your face and find when you
find out when you leave your home one of
the world's biggest spine networks is
aimed at regular people and no one can
stop it yeah and this is in China yeah
all in the name of security there's
never been a regime a government that
didn't use that as an excuse yeah you
take so the Nazis take that Hitler when
he became Chancellor took away all all
civil liberties because in the name of
protecting the fatherland from run from
essentially terrorism because a
communist lit lit the rice
on fire well what's interesting is how
long is it gonna take before some
version of this makes it over here
because it seems inevitable it's coming
but you have to be you have to fight it
tooth and [ __ ] nail Americans should
always be Miss distrustful of their
authority figures I don't give a [ __ ]
how much you like Trump or anybody else
you should hold your leaders accountable
and you should not you should always
have a healthy distrust well we were
lied to for eighteen years about how the
war was going in Afghanistan we spent
over a trillion dollars on that [ __ ]
war over the past how long has it been
since 2003 good and and we were trying
to turn into a modern nation you have
senior US officials whether intelligence
military and everybody else they knew
this was an unwinnable war I know too
many people who spent out ten years over
there they all knew it too and somehow
that just never made it out and every
general kept saying we're at a turning
point in the war we're going to defeat
the Taliban no you weren't and you know
the difference and you knew that at the
time and I understand that there's a lot
of pressure and everything else but we
spent all that money for [ __ ] in what
and a lot of Americans got injured and
[ __ ] killed for it
and we were lied to I know but this is
what's interesting about what you're
saying this is the argument for
something like this in the first place
have you had this
he had mass surveillance everywhere
people wouldn't be able to plan
terrorist attacks this is what they
always use that excuse no but that's
what they yes that's how they would
implement I know that and they could get
something like that implemented in
Afghanistan and put a giant kibosh sure
on the amount of terrorist activities
yeah right
good luck I know I would say good luck
history study history to see how that
turns out that's why studies Jason see
the thing is this kind of tools never
existed like you could study history all
day long governments usually gonna
prepare you sort of peripherally it's
not really gonna prepare you for what
what technology can do today there's
nothing in history that can really tell
you where this goes I agree with you but
but politicians use the same exact
language they've never ever which is we
have to protect the public from these
inserts this danger here's a solution
there's a solution that eventually
there's no more government here's a
solution to that you what this is doing
it's making it almost impossible to be a
traditional
to have a traditional government right
because if this stuff starts making it
into there then we can find out what
they're doing all the time so what if we
what if it turns out well we'll let you
mass surveillance on we want 24-hour
seven access to anyone who is any sort
of representative anyone who's a
congressman and it was a senator anyone
is the president we want 24/7 access to
everything you say and do we want to
know we want to know who you are no more
backs my problem with that is that you
wouldn't have the best people getting in
you don't have the best people now
that's true but it's gone there's over
you're already dealing with that as a
politician stuff I don't know if that's
the answer my thing is the answer Brian
Cowen I'm just saying imagine oh I see
I'm not saying it's a good idea it's a
terrible idea but imagine if this this
is what the world becomes everyone has
access to everyone's life see the way I
believe it is is you want to if you want
to learn about somebody as a government
agency you got major firewalls and you
need warrants and make it [ __ ]
difficult right but the reason why a
country like the United States goes to
war with a country like Afghanistan or
against the or Isis is because you have
leaders and groups yeah once there's no
leader and once there's no groups and
everybody can see everything that
everybody's doing then you have no more
need for government somebody's gonna
come but but all societies are
meditative resources no but also but you
also have to have somebody no moral
society has to have the monopoly on
violence well they understand upset war
or all the resources get distributed
evenly all natural resources lock in
common all natural resources on earth
are owned by the human beings that
inhabit the earth not the human beings
that live on that one particular spot
although out Saudi trillionaires and all
those dudes are making fracking money
that's our money [ __ ] it's our earth
you're stealing the [ __ ] essence of
the earth and selling it back to the
people how dare you Karl Marx right here
man no problem Jamie a magic contest but
all the other things you could sell you
could sell cars you can sell this you
can sell that make buildings you can I'm
not stopping capitalism but I'm saying
is all natural resource
all of them belong to the conquerors of
the earth which is us the human being a
lot of problems all of it so no no no
trillionaire oil baron's no dependence
on fossil fuels because yea fossil fuels
are great but if no one in particular is
profiting entirely off fossil fuels
because the money has to be distributed
evenly to everyone the same with solar
semen anything anything that's a
resource any natural resource yeah but
you need me enemies the technology to to
harness that stuff you tell that you
sell that but which you can't sell is
oil well we've sold on the open market
not anymore not when I'm president what
the [ __ ] dude so oils everybody you got
robbed I'm just dealing it we're
stealing it we're gonna well nuke the
world if they don't give us the oil just
listen let's start start fresh with
amoebas let's use this is not going well
let me be your vice president all right
you run okay and then what's our
platform what's our slogan the tuna in
the sea what's our slogan how do we grow
more tuna let free tuna you [ __ ] yeah
no more no more dinner theater everybody
that works in dinner theater now makes
tuna you work in a tuna plant where you
make tunas [ __ ] you like this so we have
more more tuna you were running out to
look for it you forced a breeding
program that's yes yes and you're gonna
have to filter the ocean no great
president we [ __ ] up the ocean there's
all these heavy metals and poison in
there we need a filter for the ocean
sort of like the filter that you have at
your house yeah the filters the tap
water yeah right yeah you need one of
those for the ocean problems bet to be
[ __ ] not really right not when you get
rid of music dinner theater
all musicals use the money yeah yeah I
got to make those people go to work in a
real job - yeah yeah all those people
who think that musicals are what people
want to see if you queue really [ __ ] you
go but I like oh you son of a [ __ ]
[Applause]